hi i'm steve sosnick i'm the chief
strategist at interactive brokers
my name is john hagedorn i work in
self-storage industry
i've been with the firm for over 25
years i've been in the markets for
several more before that i got involved
in investing because i wanted to make my
money
work for me and provide a better life
for my family
i try to get as many points of view as i
can um i
i subscribe to the wall street journal
that's not just for your plug that's
because it's been a necessary part of my
day for
for quite a while i really don't pay
that much attention to the stock market
if i'm being perfectly honest with you
i'm more of a set it forget it type of
investor most of my positions are long
and when i am interested in the
mormon minutia and the day-to-day
goings-on
in the stock market i typically will
turn to wall street bets because it's
where
the uh the flavor of the day type of
stuff is going on
so i saw a post from dfv early in
january
where he basically showed that gamestop
was massively shorted and at that point
the stock had started rising pretty
steadily
and that was really what led a lot of
people and myself to take a closer look
and to jump in
the best way to describe wall street
bets it is a degenerate hive
for gambling on the stock market there's
no and that's not an insult
many people that frequent wall street
bets will willingly tell you that and
wear it as a badge of honor
i describe the reddit form wall street
bets as
the latest in hundreds of years of human
beings trying to get together and
discuss uh
discuss their investments they did it
and they did it in coffee shops in
amsterdam and london they did it under a
buttonwood tree
in colonial new york and they're doing
it now on wall street bets
no i think what's what's discussed on
wall street bets
um should be more chatter among friends
um rather than um
actual advice i think that in any time
you're you're getting invest
investment advice you should figure out
what is motivating the person who is
giving that advice
it's tough to know because wall street
bets is just pure
unadulterated gambling chaos you don't
know what somebody's angle is on there
you don't know if somebody's trying to
pump a stock or dump a stock
you don't know what their goal is but
with that being said
sometimes some interesting financial
advice gets posted there and
if you are interested do your own
research
go take a look this is publicly
available information
and if you like what you see take a
position
there's never really been quite so much
focus on
let's stick it to the man or let's you
know let's bring these guys down
i think what we saw in wall street bets
over the past few weeks is really
not all that different um than a guy in
a viking hat running through the halls
of the capitol it's
it's it's in many ways a similar type of
stick it to the man type of sentiment
there's no
wizard behind the curtain directing
everybody what to do
it is pure unadulterated raw mob
mentality okay you go in there and you
can see at any given moment on wall
street bets there's a million different
people talking about a million different
things
i don't know that this is outright
manipulative and you do have to wonder
how many people were using wall street
bets
to entice others
to help out their investments rather
than trying to
help others make money through their
investments
there's nothing market manipulating
about a
totally anonymous democratic internet
forum where people can go and post what
they think
is good and what they think is bad and
what you should and shouldn't do
i'm not allowed to comment for that on
the record but let me explain
something that goes on that is not well
understood
that is a feature of markets not a bug
it was perceived as the clearinghouses
or the brokerage firms
turning over the monopoly board just as
just as the little guy was winning
in favor of the big guy um
i i think it's a lot more complicated
than that i would need to know more
about exactly what happened at robin
why did the ceo of robin hood go all
over the place
all over media and do a ton of tv
interviews and claim that
this wasn't a issue of
lack of funds on their part and that
they were doing it to
protect retail buyers and doing it to
protect their customers
there was no liquidity problem and to be
clear
this was done preemptively so we're
really in
unprecedented times and in order to
protect the firm
and protect our customers we had to
limit buying in these in these stocks
the the best thing we could do is all be
is all be educated better
everybody i could be educated better i
learned about i learned about
the little weirdness in short selling
just last week
everybody the more education that's out
there the better never
stop learning first and foremost there
needs to be
just a hard hard look at exactly what
mechanisms and tools
hedge funds use when they're shorting
companies
things like that have to be cleared up
retail investors and investors in
general
have to feel that it's a level playing
field
and right now it certainly doesn't feel
that way
you